and bryce wilson
who was acquired from the atlanta braves
and the deal for richard rodriguez
doesn't seem like he leaves much
the middle of the plate this ball hit
deep to left center field and alford
will make the catch
gaudy numbers
wow
good work though bryce wilson rookie
left-hander tyler gilbert his third
start for the diamondbacks this year so
far
no hitter against the padres and a no
decision at colorado
and there's a good start for tyler
gilbert gets the strikeout to open
things up he's also walked three times
and had a good series defensively
there's a chopper back to the mound
gilbert goes up and gets it and that's
out number two
3-2 is upstairs good take by christian
who leads it off with the base on bulls
1-1 from wilson
david knocks it into center he's gonna
base it behind walker's base on balls
and christian stops at second
got him tied him up struck him out
there we go
here's a one-two from him and a swing
and a miss dispatching rojas with that
high fastball
launches one oh that was blistered into
center
second hit for the diamondbacks a
two-out single
that was a pitch right down the middle
you can see wilson's reaction
but fortunately it's a
flyout this is lifted pretty deep left
center cattell and peralta
gets way to david there and that's the
first out in the third
goes back to that breaking ball gilbert
gets his second strikeout
well tyler gilbert how about that
another quick inning
fall four to the backstop so wilson
walks christian walker for the second
time tonight
hard hit line drive out oh
blistered off the van meter bat but
newman is there
that's good scouting
[Music]
strikeout there we go
two away
five k's
that's hard hit toward right
over is smith
off the wall
hayes into second base with a stand-up
one-out double
no-no-hitter tonight
little dribbler
throwing to third what a play safe there
dalton varshall almost got hayes but
hayes was just a bit quicker and it's
first and third
ball four snap throw safe there
the base is loaded for stallings he has
good numbers with the bases juiced
line drive to right catch made hayes has
to go back in tag and now tries to score
and he will
because the throw was just off the mark
he brian hayes had taken about four
steps toward the plate and had to
retreat
and scores on the sac fly by stallings
another strikeout number six for bryce
wilson
takes care of tyler gilbert that's seven
[Applause]
back to the fastball line the left
alford coming on to make the catch
anthony alford puts it away
line drive right field and a pick to
click
that cap said polanco was going to have
a night
and here he doubles to start the fifth
as diaz says yes
and that's strikeout number four for
tyler
oh
bad miss and a nice
pinch hit appearance for colin moran to
draw the walk comes up michael chavis
puts two pirates aboard the lineup turns
over for michael chavis
bouncing ball left side seeing eye
single polanco coming in michael chavis
delivers
it's two to nothing
did he go no and they're loaded
[Applause]
lifts it out to shallow left center
peralta's there
gilbert leaves them loaded it's going to
be nick mears retired all three st louis
batters he faced on sunday in saint
louis
and here is baby smith who was over two
flight to center fly to right
skied it deep to right field pavon smith
gives it a ride has gone
that's number 10 diamondbacks on the
board
[Applause]
boy that hung up there for the longest
time thought it might come down and give
polanco a shot but it
got over the clemente fence out there 21
feet high
walker works his third base on balls and
let's see what derek shelton wants to do
he's got his lefty ready and one time
diamondback anthony bonda who worked the
eighth inning monday struck out all
three batters he faced and got the win
david perrault to the batting average
now back up over 250. david
singled in the second his third hit in
the series
david knocks it into right field walker
stops at second he gets behind polanco
christian had come to a full stop tony
paris chica gonna send him home and he
will score it's a 2-2 ball game
arson kelly the pinch hitter
255 on the year with eight home runs he
has doubled and walked twice in the
series
carson gets it up in the air hits it
deep to left field alford at the wall
that's gone
carson kelly gives the diamondbacks the
lead
well torrey pushed the button and carson
made it happen it's 3-2 d-bags
number nine for carson kelly they were
down
three to 2-0
even a board for the second time a lead
off walk
and meter drops it in front of polanco
in right field haven stops at second
two on and one out for peralta
david knocks it into left center and
that gets to the wall
haven smith will score
here comes van mater david peralta
drives in two and it's five two
diamondbacks
wiley veteran coming on for the 13th
game this year in 12 innings
hit hard to right center field by alford
toward the wall and off the top of the
fence anthony alford rifles one 3-2 on
the way
got him tyler clifford shuts the door
diamondbacks get the 5-2 in
[Applause]
[Music]
you